I mentioned at the beginning of the show
during my segment about here's a list of
ten horrible things that Donald Trump
has made clear he's going to do during
his upcoming first term I mentioned that
trumps incoming Education Secretary Oh
is involved with a group that actually
wrote a blog post saying you know child
labor really isn't bad it's something we
should really look at I'm talking about
the Acton Institute and this is the
think-tank that's funded by trumps
Secretary of Education pick Betsy DeVos
and the Acton Institute recently
advocated for putting kids back into the
workforce they put an essay up on their
blog earlier this month and it said that
child labor is quote a gift our kids can
handle going on to say quote let us not
just teach our children to play hard and
study well shuffling them through a long
line of hobbies and electives and
educational activities a long day's work
and a load of sweat have plenty to teach
as well now child labor is not 100
percent forbidden in the US you can have
actors right there's certain rules and
they have to have a chaperone and be
taking classes on sad etcetera etc
newspaper delivery is something where
there's an accept an exemption for kids
that is made but it's pretty tightly
regulated like for example the Supreme
Court decision that upheld flag-burning
as a constitutional right which hasn't
stopped Trump from demanding stripping
of citizenship and a year in prison if
you burn a flag so not exactly a big
concern for the Trump administration
incoming administration of course
education activists and advocates are
looking at devices history and they're
very concerned the child labor thing is
obviously a concern and it makes good
headlines but she has a strong history
of supporting school voucher programs
which we know were hugely destructive to
public schools we also know that she is
not big on public schools more broadly
speaking so the child labor headline
makes a really good headline Pat but you
have someone here who is going to be the
education sector
Terry who wants to take a ton of money
away from public schools that's what we
call red alert emergency in the
political world and I love how she's
talking about child labor in this sort
of romanticized way and sweat coming
down their faces and that it builds so
much character neglecting the fact that
this is just really gonna help companies
on the other end that course a real
motivation there it's interesting that
you will have an administration which
has on the one hand of people advocating
I mean Trump took like ten different
positions on the minimum wage or six six
positions on the minimum wage but you'll
have a lot of trumpets in his
administration who want a lower or no
minimum wage and meanwhile you will have
an education secretary involved with a
group that romanticized the idea of
putting kids to work now as far as the
defunding of public schools poor kids
will have no way to get to the private
schools you want to add and partially
fund with public school money when you
take a billionaire family that was born
on third base and thinks they hit a
triple
as Chuck Collins told us in a recent
interview we did how can anything good
come from that for the average American
for the average kid when you put the
lifelong kleptocrats ludecke rat
oligarchs in power of selecting people
that will run education Trump's
selections are going to piece by piece
dismantle much of what we consider to be
the foundational direction of the US and
2016 education accessible for more
people taking climate change seriously
understanding that huge income and
wealth inequality is bad for the economy
and it's really bad for everybody
you could argue even for the very rich
although they may not see it that way a
Jeff Sessions anti-marijuana the child
labor education stuff EPA climate change
going completely backwards Trump is
going to dismantle if we allow it Pat so
much of the progress that has been made
in the last eight years and we see from
his cabinet picks that loyalty is to the
utmost importance to him